who's faster Lightning McQueen or Ricky
Bobby oo Ricky Bobby you ain't first
you're last you're getting into the car
what's the first song you're putting on
Lose Yourself by &em who's your favorite
Mario Kart driver character I always
went with toad what's your favorite
racing movie probably Talladega
kns if you weren't an F1 driver what
would you be doing feel like I still
need that adrenaline doing something I
absolutely have no idea how to DJ but it
looks like it'd be pretty cool you bring
like good energy and make a lot of
people happy you like being the
passenger Prince absolutely not I don't
trust anyone driving me what is your
favorite American sports team Miami
Dolphins followed closely by the Miami